If I pass like this, if I pass like this, if I pass like this, 6 out of 10, well 7 out of 10 will get where they're going.
I'll pass like that, they'll get to it, there you go.
But because of poor foreball not knowing how you're holding the ball, what's driving the ball, what things are important, what things are useless.
Okay, the other three are like this, or here comes someone.
Alright, so we're going to get into this bill over here, and it's going to be short, it's only one metre, so the passes are going to be just really poor.
So focus on where you're catching the ball, and where you're delivering the ball.
And try and load from here, when we expand a little bit, so you're here, and the ball hits the mark all the time.
See if you can.
Yeah, you don't have to get all, like what we used to do in the 70s.
You're squared, because this guy wants to take my head off here.
So I'm here, and I'm squared to my man, come again, and we're not following the pass.
See, I'm not following him, because he'll kill me if he sees this.
Alright, and that's easy, that's just ambush predator.
Alright, questions on that?
Tony, there's...
See real...
See ribs, eat ribs.
Is that what they call it?
Yep, I like that.
I just learned something today.
Questions on that?
Anybody having trouble with their passing, or having trouble passing one way?
On you.
It's okay?
Okay, you've got to do it, and you've got to practice it, you've got to understand the mechanics of it.
It's just a ball, and how it's going to get there, how you can get that power and accuracy.
And just come off, right, if I want to hit your head, fingers are going up to the head.
That's what I, that's just me, I'll coach that, alright, if I want it to go to his hips, I'll point down here.
Alright, I'm a little bit congested, because I'm short, and Jesus gave me that right to be.
So when the buffaloes are coming to get me, I'll get the pass away, and I'm already kind of ready for impact, versus the tall timber.
Because if they have balls, I'm ready to go.
Alright .
Now a quick drink.